uh well this is not the exact time I  would have loved to travel I would have  loved to travel later in the afternoon  but I couldn't get a train so I've had  to come in start my journey earlier uh  to be able to get to Wakefield uh before  the train  um strikes uh begin when we were like  looking for three and online there were  no more left like every ticket was sold  out and my sister couldn't get one so  we're gonna get on the train and  hopefully buy one on the train it's um  it's all it's all been all been I caught  a plan  um we haven't had any delays or anything  like that and even coming down here  yesterday everything everything runs  smoothly so